seit den frühesten Tagen war die
Pressefreiheit das was Amerika
ausmachte an
unabhäigiterklärb für unverzichtbar und
sagte wenn es mir überlassen bliebe zu
entscheiden ob wir eine Regierung ohne
Zeitungen oder Zeitungen ohne eine
Regierung haben sollten würde ich keinen
Augenblick zögern das letztere
vorzuziehen das war im Jahr
1787 heute scheinen unsere Zeitungen an
Bedeutung zu verlieren in einer
multimedialen Welt die weitgehend im
Besitz und unter der Kontrolle einer
Handvoll großer Medienkonzerne
ist wir sindinlich die Medi beherchte
Gesellschaft der Welt Jeff Cohen hat in
den großen Medien gearbeitet jetzt ist
er einer der schärfsten Kritiker der
Branche ein halbes Dutzend Unternehmen
besitzt und kontrolliert den größten
Teil der Mainstream Medien in unserem
Land wenn man sich also ansieht wer
Amerika regiert oder wem Amerika gehört
dann sind es dieselben Leute die Amerika
propagieren die Presse und die Medien
die über Nachrichten berichten oder
Informationen vermitteln sind nur ein
kleiner Teil
medieneriums das unterhaltungsprodukte
herstellt die auch eine auf
konsumbasierende Lebensweise
verkaufen wenn man sich ansieht wer in
den Vorständen der Medienkonzerne sitzt
die sitzen auch in den Vorständen der US
Ölkonzerne und der Militärunternehmen
wenn man also untersucht wie Amerika
gehört dann sind das auch die Leute
denen die Medien gehören wir haben keine
staatlichen Medien aber in mancher
Hinsicht sind sie den staatlichen med
sehr ähnlich es ist Hal der ST der
Unternehmen wenn das wahr ist können wir
sagen dass die US-Medien nicht nur über
Nachrichten berichten wie wir sehen
werden sind sie nicht unabhängig vom
System sondern seine Stütze sie
verstärken die Weltanschauung und
verteidigen die Interessen derjenigen
die Amerika
beherrschen vor 30 Jahren beherrschten
50 Unternehmen die amerikanischen Medien
jetzt sind es nur noch sechs hier sind
einige Diagramme zum medienbesitz die
diese Konzentration
verdeutlichen mit der zunehmenden
Bedeutung neuer globaler digitaler
Unternehmen wie Google Facebook und
Twitter wurden die US-amerikanischen
Medien zu einer transnationalen
Kraft die us-medienunternehmen befinden
sich zu einem großen Teil im Besitz von
Hedgefonds Investmentfonds und
Finanzunternehmen
Berry James dike ist ein
Vermögensverwalter der sich mit
medienbesitz beschäftigt hat die
Untersuchungen die ich durchgeführt habe
sind eindeutig ich bin sozusagen darüber
gestolert die großen Medienunternehmen
die Disneys die CBS die
nachrichtenkonzerne sie alle und das
sind alles öffentliche Dokumente sind im
Besitz von Investmentfond Gesellschaften
die Mehrheit der Aktionäre ist im Besitz
solcher Gesellschaften sie beziehen also
auch einen Großteil ihrer Einnahmen von
diesen Unternehmen sie werden also nie
eine konsequente Kritik an ihnen
hören werden diese Unternehmen von den
Medien untersucht nein werden sie nicht
sind sie gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit in
irgendeiner Weise verantwortlich
rechenschaftspflichtig weiß die
Öffentlichkeit was sie tun die
Öffentlichkeit hat keine Ahnung sie
wissen nicht was sie tun er hat seine
Erkenntnisse in seinem Buch the pirates
of Manhattan
dokumentiert nun die Menschen werden die
Wahrheit nicht erfahren
aber es gibt viel Berichterstattung vor
allem über Politik die oft wie ein
Sportereignis behandelt wird wobei der
Schwerpunkt auf Umfrage Werten und
Wahlergebnissen liegt Mary Boyle
verfolgt die Berichterstattung über
Wahlen für common cause wie sehen sie
die Rolle der Medien tragen Sie dazu bei
unsere Demokratie zu stärken oder tragen
Sie dazu bei uns zu
spalten das ist eine gute Frage ich
glaube dass hier mehrere Dinge vor sich
gehen offensichtlich gibt es eine Art
von Kabelkanälen die in verschiedenen
Lagern sind und sie zeigen keine
verschiedenen Standpunkte es gibt Fox
News die die Rechten zeigen MSNBC zeigt
die
Linke bei einer solchen Konstellation
schalten die Amerikaner einfach den
Sender ein den sie hören wollen und der
ihre Ansichten
vertritt ohne dass sie eine Mischung aus
Meinungen Debatten oder ähnlichem sehen
hinzu kommt dass die Medien immer
kleiner
es wird weniger darüber berichtet was
vor sich
geht und ich glaube das betrifft vor
allem die Landes und Kommunalpolitik wo
noch weniger über das politische
Geschehen berichtet
wird auch wenn die Welt für ihre
Vielfalt bekannt ist die US-Medien sind
es nicht in redaktioneller und
ideologischer Hinsicht neigt die
Machtelite dazu die Ansichten der
Regierung
wiederzuspiegeln Andersdenkende
Politiker wie der Kongressabgeordnete
Jess Jackson junor haben es schwer sich
mit ihren Ansichten gehört zu
verschaffen wem gehören die Medien wie
wird das alles umgesetzt einige der
Mogule und Titanen der Medien und der
Industrie sind Teil des Problems sie
formen ein narrativ für das
amerikanische Volk eines das
letztendlich Millionen von Menschen dazu
bringt für Kandidaten zu stimmen die auf
dem narrativ basieren das sie formen
basierend auf den Moderatoren die sie
kontrollieren und die diese Amerikaner
neigen dazu auf der Grundlage dessen was
sie hören zu wählen und sich für das
System zu engagieren die Medien sind ein
wesentlicher Teil des Problems der
Historiker Eric foner stimmt dem zu er
sagt es geäbe hier nicht nur politische
Voreingenommenheit sondern auch das
worauf sich die Medien als Unternehmen
konzentrieren müssen um Einschaltquoten
und Einnahmen zu
erzielen irgendwie ist die Vorstellung
von der Macht die hinter den Menschen im
Amt steht in unseren Medien nicht sehr
präsent auch nicht wirklich in den
Köpfen der Menschen sie personalisieren
die Politik es gibt Persönlichkeiten die
sich gegenseitig bekämpfen aber sie
schauen nicht darauf wer hinter den
Kulissen
steht sie haben Recht dass die Medien
sich auf Persönlichkeiten konzentrieren
und oft sind es die Maen der
Persönlichkeiten Clintons sexuelle
esapaden oder ob Obama in den
Vereinigten Staaten geboren wurde oder
nicht oder Romney und seine Autos und
was auch immer sie wissen schon dass er
keine Steuern zahlt und all das das sind
keine völlig unwichtigen Themen aber
vielleicht liegt es an der Natur der
Medien von heute dass sie sich auf die
schnell Nachrichten konzentrieren müssen
das tiefgründige investigative
Berichterstattung nicht so sehr im
Vordergrund steht wie es vielleicht in
der Vergangenheit der Fall war man muss
Zeitungen verkaufen und Skandale
verkaufen Zeitungen Persönlichkeiten
verkaufen Zeitungen
prominenzverkaufzeitungen sie haben also
recht dass die größeren Zusammenhänge
des Systems nicht mehr so stark betont
werden
es wird von vielen Leuten nicht mal
verstanden nun es ist schwer zu
verstehen es handelt sich um ein sehr
großes Land mit über 300 Millionen
Einwohnern und einem sehr komplizierten
wirtschaftlichen und politischen System
es ist schwierig genau zu verstehen wie
die Dinge funktionieren aber ich glaube
in gewissem Sinne ist die in diesem Land
weit verbreitete
antiregierungsstimmung die im
Allgemeinen mit dem rechten Flügel in
Verbindung gebracht wird auch eine
Reaktion auf das unbestimmte Gefühl kein
analy
h die Regierung unnbar ist dass sie
nicht regiert dass sie die Menschen
nicht wirklich vertritt dass sie einige
sehr spezielle Interessen vertritt und
dieses Gefühl ist in diesem Land
ziemlich weit
verbreitet
medienbeobachtungsgruppen sind auch
besorgt über die mangelnde Vielfalt in
den Medien wodurch sie nicht mehr
repräsentativ sind für das Land dem sie
dienen in Bezug auf Rasse und
Geschlecht
der New York Times lautet verärgere
nicht diejenigen von denen wir in Bezug
auf Geld und Zugang abhängig
sind war ein preisgekrönter Journalist
für die New York Times ein
amerikanischer
Medienstar das sind also die Machtelite
und die Finanziers die Werbung machen
aber es ist ausbaufähig ich meine man
hat zumindest in den Positionen in denen
ich war die mögkeitournalism betreiben
nicht dass es keine Einschränkungen gebe
oder dass es keine Bestrafungen
gäbees Arbeit wird nach wie vor sehr
geschätzt aber er ist der Meinung dass
ein Großteil der Presse letztlich eine
FAS ist die die Macht mehr deckt als
über sie zu berichten vor allem bei der
Berichterstattung über
wahen den das politische Theater also
diese persönlichen Stories der
Kandidaten das irrelevant es ist
bedeutungslos und die Leute wir spielen
das Spiel spielen diese Charade wir
spielen sie wenn wir gefügige
Konzernmedien haben die so tun als sei
diese Charade echt ich glaube das
Problem ist dass die Illusion immer noch
so stark ist die Menschen ändern sich
aber die Illusion ist immer noch so
mächtig dass die Leute verwechseln wo
die macht tatsächlich
existiert wie berichtet die New York
Times über die Machtzentren von denen
viele sagen dass sie Amerika beherrschen
Chris Banos ist Redakteur des New York
Times examiner der täglich die Inhalte
der Zeitung überprüft seiner Meinung
nach ist die Zeitung zum Komplizen der
Machtelite
geworden die New York Times ist fast für
eine minination und die Korrespondenten
die Verfasser von meinungsbeiträgen die
Redakteure sind fast wie Diplomaten so
wie Sie sich und Ihre selbslichkeit
darstellen so wie sie mit anderen
Politikern und Diplomaten kommunizieren
und sie sind sehr
einflussreich würden Sie sagen dass Sie
in Amerika nicht nur Informationen
sondern auch Ideologien
verbreiten auf jeden Fall sie verbreiten
eine ganz bestimmte Ideologie denn ihre
Leserschaft besteht hauptsächlich aus
Managern und Leuten die mehr als 90 000$
im Jahr verdienen sie bedienen also die
Perspektive von Managern wenn Sie also
über Arbeitsbeziehungen diskutieren
haben sie oft eine proagement Sicht eine
prosinessicht Finanzjournalisten wie
Stacy Herbert und Max Kaiser fanden
heraus dass viele wirtschaftsfreundliche
Berichte in einigen Medien schlecht
recherchiert waren wie sie mir in einer
Radiosendung
sagten im Dezember 2008 also kurz nach
dem Zusammenbruch von B STS und lean
Brothers stürzten die Märkte an einem
Tag um 1000 Punkte ab und der Leiter von
BC world new business sagte wir hatten
einen Vertrag über zehn Folgen er sagte
glauben Sie dass die Finanzkrise bis zum
Ende dieser zehn Folgen andauern
wird mit anderen Worten die Leute die
für die Planung der Berichterstattung
zuständig sind sind selbst sehr schlecht
informiert nun die Mainstream Medien
sind selbst hoch verschuldet die
nachrichtenorganisationen sind zu
unterhaltungsunternehmen geworden und um
konkurrenzfähig zu sein nehmen Sie
enorme Schulden auf die ber wollen also
ihre glub nicht beleidigen weil sie
ihnen die Kreditlinien kürzen könnten
sie sind in dieser Hinsicht nicht
unvoreingenommen beim besten Willen
nicht am spektakulärsten ist das bei der
New York Times zu beobachten ihre
Berichterstattung über die Wall Street
ist
erbärmlich ein Grund warum die Presse so
wirtschaftsfreundlich ist ist dass sie
selbst ein Unternehmen ist die Leute die
Medien Unternehmen leiten zahlen sich
zunehmend selbst riesige Gehälter und
Boni Sowi es auch bker
agtryon ich konnte es nicht glauben er
hat 2009 59 Millionen Dollar verdient
und er hat wie neulich zu lesen war 2010
fast 70 Millionen Dollar verdient das
ist der Chef von CBS das ist der Chef
von CBS sie sagen dass sie alle ihre
Unternehmen so führen als wären sie
Banken das ist ziemlich gut ein Banker
Gehalt ich meine 70 millionenll sind
eine Menge Geld und das bekommen sie
bezahlteh sind also Teil dieses ganzen
Systems wer regiert
Amerika sie sind Teil dieser
ineinandergreifenden Beziehungen mit den
Finanzinstituten daran besteht kein
Zweifel da sind die Medienunternehmen
die riesig sind sie sind Teil des
Imperiums dann gibt es natürlich die
Banker da sind die großen Gewerkschaften
und da gibt es noch weitere Faktoren
aber die Medien gehören definitiv dazu
und die
Vermögensverwalter
genauso ist es die Konzerne denen die
US-Medien und das Fernsehen gehören sind
sehr wohlhabend und mächtig und die
Leute an der Spitze der
Nachrichtensender bekommen sehr viel
Geld ich habe nie auch nur annäherend so
viel Geld verdient wie in dem einen Jahr
an dem General Electric mein Chef bei
MSNBC war meiner Meinung nach findet
also eine Selbstzensur statt bei der die
Leute die an die Spitze aufsteigen
gelernt haben wie sie keinen Ärger
machen und sie wissen dass sie ihre
hohen Gehälter verlieren wenn sie Ärger
machen
Zeitungen wie die New York Times die
Washington Post und das Wall Street
Journal neigen dazu ein narrativ zu
entwerfen das uns sagt was wir für
wichtig halten
sollen sie geben die Agenda vor die auch
die Berichterstattung in den
Nachrichtensendungen beeinflusst sie
befassen sich nicht mit Ungleichheit und
Klassenunterschieden sagt der
unabhängige Medienmanager Brian dry
sie sprechen nicht über die
Arbeiterklasse das liegt zum Teil auch
daran dass sie die Idee propagieren dass
man gewinnen kann wenn man ein lotterios
kauft also denkt man wirklich dass man
vielleicht gewinnen könnte wenn du also
zur Arbeiterklasse gehörst oder
arbeitslos bist hast du immer noch die
Hoffnung dass du irgendwie in die
Mittelklasse aufsteigen
wirst der Klasse an sich wird sehr wenig
Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt sie sagten dass
die Medien das nicht wirklich
diskutieren Sie die Klassenunterschiede
in Amerika nicht wirklich hervor sie
sprechen viel lieber über
Rassenunterschiede oder ethnische
Unterschiede gleichzeitig sind sie sich
bei ihren Geschäftspraktiken der
demografischen Entwicklung sehr bewusst
welche Bevölkerungsschicht sprechen Sie
an die Oberschicht wie Sie Ihre Werbung
gestalten wie Sie Ihr was verkaufen
können nein sie ich meine das Internet
ist ein perfektes Beispiel dafür sie
wissen schon alles wo sie einen ständig
in scheibenschneiden und zerlegen damit
Sie genau wissen wie viel man verdient
und welches Produkt sie einem dann
anbieten können das ist dieser ganze
Wahnsinn der Konsumgesellschaft den der
moderne Kapitalismus geschaffen hat aber
der springendeer Punkt auf den sie
hinaus wollen ist dass es zwar eine
klassenrealität gibt eine Arbeiterklasse
und eine herrschende Klasse oder eine
borgeoisie aber die Menschen sind darauf
trainiert worden nicht in diesen
Begriffen zu denken sodass sie nicht
einm wissen wer sie
sind einige Sender wie Fox new das
Rupert Murdock gehört scheinen sich mit
der Stellung einer rechten politischen
Linie wohler zu fühlen sie haben dazu
beigetragen dass viele Medien nach
rechts gerückt sind es gibt Leute die
sagen wir hätten den Bürgern von Bagdad
48 Stunden Zeit geben sollen den is zu
verlassen und platt zu machen dann wäre
der Krieg schon
vorbei das mag sein aber die alten
Medien werden von den neuen in den
Schatten gestellt sagt georgeripner
Vizepräsident von Digitas einem
Unternehmen das digitale Strategien für
große Unternehmen entwickelt und
untersucht wie wohlhabende Verbraucher
das men in einer Zeit wachsender
wirtschaftlicher
Ungleichheit das einzige was jetzt
anders ist ist dass die Medien allen
gehören das einzige was die Dollars bis
zu einem gewissen Grad ausgleicht ist
die Tatsache dass jeder Zugang zu
Twitter hat Zugang zum Bloggen und dass
es diese neue Art der schnellen und
flüssigen Koalitionsbildung gibt up Wall
Stre war ein Beispiel dafür der
arabische Frühling in gewisser Weise
gibt es eine neue Kontrolle und ein
neues Gleichgewicht ich glaube nicht
dass sich dadurch unbedingt die
Umstrukturierung von Einkommen und
Vermögen ändert aber ich glaube dass es
einen weiteren Schalter gibt der uns
helfen könnte wenn die Dinge zu schlimm
werden die digitalen Medien sind also in
gewisser Weise der Ort an dem die
Demokratie heute ist nicht in der
Politik nicht in der Wirtschaft nicht
beim großen Geld so ist es gut
gesagt es gibt eine Debatte darüber wie
frei das Internet wirklich ist
angesichts der Kontrolle durch
Unternehmen und der staatlichen Zensur
aber es ermöglicht mehr Interaktivität
gleichzeitig dreht sich die
Aufmerksamkeit der Medien immer noch um
eine politische Elite mit
Autorität auch wenn diese Elite nicht
unbedingt die Macht hat Prioritäten
zusetzen oder politische Maßnahmen
durchzusetzen aber wenn man mit normalen
Amerikanern spricht empfinden viele von
ihnen das als völlig fair sie sehen
verschiedene Standpunkte sie sehen
Menschen die von Zeit zu Zeit kritisch
sind sie sehen die Medien als die
Liberalen
Medien ich war in der Sowjetunion und
wir wurden in diesem Land immer damit
aufgezogen dass das reine Propaganda ist
und ehrlich gesagt war das eine sehr
unwirksame Propaganda weil sie nie
Vorgaben zwei Standpunkte zu haben sie
vertraten immer nur einen Standpunkt und
sagten wie toll die Dinge sind aber in
unserem Land ist die Propaganda wirklich
effektiv weil sie den Anschein einer
Debatte
erweckt die Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika werden nicht zulassen dass die
gefährlichsten Regime der Welt uns
bedrohen Jeff Cohen sagt dass die
Amerikaner vor den Krieg über den Irak
in die Irre geführt wurden und heute
über den Iran in die Irre geführt werden
er verwies auf eine Studie über den Irak
vor der amerikanischen Invasion die
zeigte dass von etwa
393 Personen die von allen sändern
befragt wurden nur drei gegen den Krieg
waren denn fast alles was wir vor der
Invasion über den Irak wussten erwies
sich als falsch undast alles was wir
heute über den Iran erfahren ist nicht
korrekt vor ein paar Monaten haben wir
in der New York Times gelesen dass die
Internationale Atomenergieorganisation
eine Einschätzung veröffentlicht hat
dass das iranische Atomprogramm ein
militärisches Ziel verfolgt und fair
diese medienkritische Gruppe ging zur
times und sagte welcher Bericht ist das
wir haben noch nie davon gehört die
Times wusste dass sie ein großer Fehler
unterlaufen war es war ein bedeutender
Fehler sie entfernten den Satz von Ihrer
Website weiger sich aber den Fehler zu
korrigieren es sind nicht nur Kriege die
propagiert werden die Medien berichten
nicht oft über die Menschen hinter den
Kulissen die die Dinge leiten sagt
William Hartung der über den militärisch
industriellen Komplex geschrieben
hat man sollte meinen dass der
Journalismus bei diesem Thema eine
gewisse Unabhängigkeit an den Tag legt
aber in einigen Fällen haben Reporter zu
mir gesagt na ja wissen Sie ich kann das
Pentagon nicht härter angehen oder die
Unternehmen weil sie ein großer
Anzeigenkunde der Zeitung sind wir
werden unter Druck gesetzt wenn wir
solche Geschichten bringen wir berichten
also über den Krieg in Afghanistan wir
wiederholen was der Präsident zu
bestimmten Themen sagt und es gibt nicht
wirklich viele Interessen oder
Ressourcen um solche Verbindungen zu
untersuchen David Swanson der auch über
Militärpolitik schreibt stimmt dem
zu die Konzernmedien sind mit dem
militärischindustriellen Komplex
verflochten einige Unternehmen machen
mit beiden Profit
es gibt zwei große politische Parteien
die sich in dieser Frage nicht sehr
uneinig sind also steht es nicht zur
Debatte egal ob sich 90% der
Öffentlichkeit darüber aufregen es ist
keine akzeptable
Nachricht Michael CL der die
zerstörerische Macht der Öl und
Gasunternehmen untersucht hat sagt dass
das gleiche gilt wenn es um diese
Industrie
geht die Medien berichten größenteils
nicht darüber tatsächlich sind die
Medien aufgrund der Werbegelder die die
Öl und gaslobby zur Verfügung ST
weitgehend gleichgeschaltet sie sind in
hohem Maße von den Werbeeinnahmen
abhängig und daher sehr vorsichtig mit
ihren
Aussagen das Großkapital ein
wohlhabender und häufiger Inserent in
den Medien wird von den Medien oft nicht
kritisch beeugt das war auch während der
Finanzkrise so sagt Krumholz vom Center
for responsive
politics es sind komplizierte Themen an
einem guten Tag sind die Themen schwer
zu verstehen und sie scheinen dem
Durchschnittsamerikaner sehr
undurchsichtig und unwichtig zu
sein es ist also möglich dass einige
Medien sich abgemüht haben zu erklären
warum das wichtige Informationen sind
die die Wähler
brauchen aber ich glaube dass die Medien
einen Großteil der Schuld am
finanziellen Zusammenbruch tragen
letztendlich wissen wir und das ist
entscheidend wenn es ein perfektes
Szenario gibt das zeigt warum
Aufmerksamkeit so wichtig
das Hinterfragen der mächtigen Akteure
und was sie wollen und was Sie tun um
ihren Willen zu
bekommen dann ist die Finanzkrise das
perfekte
Beispiel es zeigt uns wie wichtig
Transparenz
ist großer Reichtum erfordert große
Aufmerksamkeit gemeinsam können wir
Ihnen und Ihrem Vermögen die Flügel
verleihen um
[Musik]
aufzusteigen
management gleichzeitig sind die Medien
so allgegenwärtig geworden online und
offline im Fernsehen und auf den Handys
dass viele Amerikaner sagen sie sein
Opfer einer Informationsflut geworden je
mehr sie sehen desto weniger wissen
[Musik]
Sie die Informationsflut ist meiner
Meinung nach eine ernsthafte Bedrohung
für die Demokratie denn sie funktioniert
nicht wenn die Menschen nicht wachsam
sind niemand wird die Mitglieder des
Kongress für dich zur Rechenschaft
ziehen du musst sicherstellen dass du
gehört
wirst ich glaube es gibt auch das Gefühl
dass es Spannungen gibt manche würden
sagen eine gesunde Spannung zwischen der
Sorge um den Schutz des Prozesses der
Demokratie und der Regierung vor
ungebürlichem Einfluss des Geldes und
dem Schutz der Redefreiheit und der
Privatsphäre niemand will Informationen
zensieren wir wollen unsere über alle
Informationen verfügen auch wenn sie von
finanzstarken Unternehmen Gewerkschaften
oder handelsverbänden stammen also von
sehr eng gefassten Interessen wir wollen
nur sicherstellen dass sie ihrer Aufgabe
nachkommen und nach alternativen
Perspektiven suchen auch wenn sie von
Gruppen kommen die keine Macht und kein
Geld
haben in der Medienkritik geht es in der
Regel darum worüber berichtet wird und
worüber nicht und nicht darum wie die
Erzählungen der Medien unser Denken
das ist die Macht der Medien und der
Grund warum sie jetzt zu den Kräften
gehören die Amerika
[Applaus]
regieren jedes Schulkind lernt dass die
Macht in Washington formell
geteilt Ex das von Barack Obama besetzt
ist der Judikative an deren Spitze der
Oberste Gerichtshof mit neuen Richtern
steht die alle von der Politik ernannt
wurden und der Legislative in der der
Senat 100 Mitglieder hat davon zwei aus
jedem Bundesstaat und das
Repräsentantenhaus
435 die aus Bezirken in ganz Amerika
stammen dies ist das formale System der
gegenseitigen Kontrolle dass das Land
auf dem stabilen Kurs der Demokratie
halten soll
doch wo immer man in dieser Hauptstadt
Amerikas hingeht und mit den Menschen
zusammentrifft die am besten darüber
informiert sind wie die Regierung
wirklich funktioniert hört man dass das
System nicht funktioniert und dass die
Wähler nicht das Sagen haben wir hören
es von einem Mitglied des Kongresses wer
kontrolliert
Amerika eine elitäre Gruppe von Menschen
die in einer Stratosphäre auf der ganzen
Welt agieren jenseits der Verfassung
jenseits der Reichweite der Regierung
sie über enorme
Ressourcen wir hören es von einer
Expertin für
Wahlen unsere Politik wird gekarpert sie
wird von Leuten gekarpert die bereit
sind Millionen von Dollar auszugeben um
bestimmte Kandidaten zu wählen oder zu
besiegen wir hören es vom Leiter einer
öffentlichen
Interessengruppe wir haben eine
unternehmensplutokratie die Regeln in
Washington werden von den Lobbyisten
geschrieben die im Namen der größten
Unternehmensinteressen im Lande arbeiten
und wir hören über Lobbyisten von einem
erfahrenen ehemaligen Mitarbeiter des
Kongresses der nur mit uns sprechen will
wenn sein Gesicht und seine Stimme
verfremdet werden
99% der Leute die ich im Kongress als
Lobbyisten sehe sind weiße Männer und
Frauen denen man ansieht dass sie sehr
schöne teure Anzüge Krawatten und
Kleider tragen und in die Büros der
Republikaner gehen ich sehe hier selten
Afroamerikaner ich sehe selten
hispanoamerikaner oder
ODL man sieht diese sehr gut bekleideten
Typen die gerade aus einemet gestiegen
sind und direkt aus dem Country Club
kommen und sie gehen in die Büros der
Republikaner und bitten um irgendeine
Steuersenkung das sind nicht nur
Meinungen dieses gut recherchierte Buch
von William Domhof beschreibt
detailliert wie die Regierung heute von
mächtigenitären Kräften außerhalb der
Regierung geführt wird wie wir sehen
werden werden seine Schlussfolgerung von
erfahrenen Insidern hier in Washington
DC
unterstützt all diese insider sagen dass
Geld und special interests jetzt die
Kontrolle haben auch sie fragen sich wer
regiert Amerika in Washington sprachen
wir mit führenden Vertretern Dreier
angesehener
Überwachungsorganisationen die sich auf
die Erforschung verborgener Kräfte
spezialisiert haben die hinter den
Kulissen
wirken public citizen konzentriert sich
auf die Themen Korruption und
Rechenschaftspflicht robert weem ist ihr
Präsident und beschrieb wie Gesetze
verabschiedet werden wie entsteht ein
Gesetzesentwurf wie wird es zum Gesetz
wie wird es umgesetzt und wie wird es
durchgesetzt bei jedem Schritt auf dem
Weg dorthin dominieren die Konzerne der
jeweiligen Branche den
Prozess warum stellen die
Kongressabgeordneten die wir wählen
dieses System nicht in
Frage nun sie sind Produkte des Systems
also neigen sie dazu es zu begünstigen
sie haben in diesem System Erfolg gehabt
und diejenigen die das System in Frage
stellen müssen gegen die etablierte
Macht kämpfen die Leute sind nach
Washington gekommen weil sie
herausgefunden haben wie sie das System
für sich nutzen können selbst wenn sie
als Insider gekommen sind werden sie
schnell darüber aufgeklärt wie die Dinge
hier laufen wenn sie hoffen etwas zu
erreichen also unterwerfen sie sich den
Interessen der
Unternehmen woher kommt das Geld die 100
größten Spender haben
Geldes gespendet das an super geht das
heit 1% der Spender stellt 64% des
Geldes zur Verfügung es ist eine winzige
Elite die es sich leisten kann die
Beiträge zu leisten die in diesem
wahlzyklus am einflussreichsten sein
werden diese Webseite
opensecrets.org dokumentiert woher das
ganze Geld in der Politik
stammtilrumholz leitet sie als
Geschäftsführerin des Center for
responsive
politics
ich glaube viele der Menschen die sich
über die Rolle des Geldes in Washington
Sorgen machen und darüber wie es
privaten engstirnigen Interessen den Weg
ebnet glauben dass das Geld das die
Mitglieder des Kongresses und die
politischen Entscheidungsträger die
Hebel der Macht
kontrollieren aber dass die Spender die
Gönner dieser Leute die Fäden in der
Hand
haben die
sindzag Schauplatz der macht aber die
Leute die hinter ihnen stehen haben das
sagen wie finden wir heraus wer diese
Leute
sind nun wir haben Millionen und aber
Millionen von Aufzeichnungen üb Spenden
an Kandidaten politische aktionskomites
einschließlich leadershipspacks die eine
Art schmiergeldkasse sind die sie
kontrollieren und an Parteien wir können
auch sehen das Geld direkt an die
superpacks geht das sind politische
aktionsausschüsse die eigentlich nur
Beiträge an Gruppen leisten sollen die
Geld für Dinge ausgeben die unabhängig
von Kampagnen und Parteien
sind das Problem ist dass es diesen
geheimen Geldtopf gibt der von Gruppen
gefüllt wird die nicht offenlegen woher
das Geld
kommt und sie schalten politische
Werbung die oft ziemlich vernichtend und
Böse und manchmal unverantwortlich ist
aber sehr
einflussreich und wir haben keine Ahnung
woher das Geld kommt
sie erklärte uns die Daten eine kleine
Minderheit kontrolliert den Prozess mit
sehr wenigen Millionären die die ganze
Politik
finanzieren es gibt 610 registrierte
superpacks 195 von ihnen haben bisher
das Geld für die Werbung aufgebracht
aber dieses Diagramm zeigt wie
dramatisch die Ausgaben dieser Gruppen
für Werbung gestiegen
sind im Jahr 2012 haben wirusgaben von
über 100 Millionen das sind 100% mehr
als 2008 und 400% mehr als im letzten
Zyklus dies ist ein HU is HU der
Lobbyisten in Washington zwischen
1998 und
2012 die US-Handelskammer gab 831
Millionen Dollar
aus die American Medical Association 269
Millionen Dollar General Electric 268
Millionen Dollar
die
PH geben zu mehr als 219 Millionen
Dollar für Lobbyarbeit ausgegeben zu
haben und es gibt noch viele viele
mehr das Jahr 2012 könnte einen
Wendepunkt in der amerikanischen Politik
werden wegen des vielen Geldes das
buchstäblich investiert wird Mary Bo ist
die Vizepräsidentin von
commonuse wenn es darum geht wer Amerika
regiert muss manlich ansehen die das
meiste Geld für politische Kampagnen
Spenden es sind sehr einflussreiche
Leute die viel Geld für politische
Kampagnen Spenden Millionen von Dollar
und die etwas dafür zurückhaben wollen
in der Regel handelt es sich um sehr
erfahrene Geschäftsleute die viel Geld
verdient haben weil sie wissen was sie
tun und sie tätigen keine Investitionen
ohne eine Gegenleistung zu
erwarten das ist bedauerlich aber damit
wird Medienzeit gekauft auch mailingak
und natürlich werden damit auch
Kandidaten unterstützt die letztlich in
den US-Kongress einziehen und vielleicht
in ihrem Sinne
abstimmen die größten Geldgeber für
politische Kampagnen in Amerika sind die
Finanzinstitute die zweitgrößten Spender
sind die großen Bauträger das heißt dass
sie wenn sie für ein Amt kandidieren
gewählt werden müssen indem sie
versprechen eine Politik zu unterstützen
die v immobiliekor üzt wird und vom
Finanzsektor der Kredite an den
Immobiliensektor
vergibt ist die Demokratie dadurch nicht
in
Gefahr ja ich meine dank citizens United
und einer Reihe anderer Gerichtsurteile
können Unternehmen jetzt mehr Geld
spenden als es ihnen jemals zuvor
erlaubt war und das ist sicherlich eine
Bedrohung für unsere Demokratie denn
dadurch werden die Stimmen der normalen
Menschen übertönt
es ist in gewisser Weise entmutigend
dass die Wahlen von 2008 gezeigt haben
dass eine enorme Anzahl von Menschen
Veränderungen will und dennoch scheint
es auf Schritt und Tritt Widerstand von
Minderheiten zu geben die sehr geschickt
darin sind Veränderungen zu
unterminieren sicherlich war 2008 die
Wahl des Wandels und wir waren
enttäuscht dass aus dem Weißen Haus
nicht mehr Veränderung
kam
nun da Präsident Obama sich zur
Wiederwahl stellt verbringt auch er die
meiste Zeit damit Geld zu beschaffen 2
Milliarden Dollar für politische
Kampagnen deshalb sagt Robert weismanan
dass dieser Skandal beide Parteien
betrifft ja das ist sicher ein
überparteiliches Problem die 2
Milliarden Dollar beziehen sich nur auf
das
Präsidentschaftsrennen das gesamte
nationale Rennen wird sich wohl auf 8
Milliarden belaufen Obama ist ein extrem
talentierter Spendensammler also wird er
viel Geld auftreiben können die riesigen
Summen die von Superreichen und
Unternehmen kommen werden aber wohl
überwiegend an die Republikaner
gehen es ist so teuer für ein Amt zu
kandidieren egal ob es sich um das
Präsidentenamt handelt oder die
Legislative eines Bundesstaates man muss
losziehen und Geld von Leuten sammeln
die eine Gegenleistung dafür wollen das
Geld in der Politik finanziert nicht nur
die Kandidaten es bezahlt die
Lobbyarbeit im Jahr 2011 gab es
12654 Lobbyisten die
Milliarden Dollar für die Beeinflussung
von Politikern Behörden und
regierungsstellenausgaben letzte Woche
war ich mit einer Gruppe von 20 Frauen
aus dem Nahen Osten zusammen sie wollten
etwas über Code pink erfahren und ich
sagte kommt zum Kongress und lernt uns
kennen wir traffen uns in der Cafeteria
und sahen uns um und sagten all diese
Leute betreiben Lobbyarbeit im Kongress
und glauben dass sie Einfluss haben aber
der Einfluss findet nicht hier statt es
gibt einen besonderen Ort im Kapitol wo
die Leute die Geld haben hingehen um
Lobbyarbeit zu betreiben sie haben auch
ihre speziellen Partys bei denen Sie
viel Geld bezahlen um ihren
Kongressabgeordneten persönlich zu
treffen dort werden die Dinge erledigt
laut der Wissenschaftlerin Francis Fox
pivin liegt das an einem anderen Problem
nicht alle Amerikaner können oder wollen
wählen wir haben ein sehr entwickeltes
sehr verdrehtes und verzerrtes System
der
es ist nicht nur durch das große Geld
verzehrt obwohl das natürlich sehr sehr
wichtig ist weil es die Werbung und den
Wahlkampf
ermöglicht viele Menschen sind aber gar
nicht wahlberechtigt und selbst
diejenigen die wähen sind nicht gerecht
vertreten die Menschen in kleineren
Staaten sind besser
vertreten das erklärt warum kleine aber
gut finanzierte Gruppen wie die
proisrael Lobby oder die
viel Einfluss
haben hat untersucht wer Außenpolitik
macht es ist ein informelles Netzwerk
von Leuten die Amerika regieren auch
wenn sie nicht mit Schildern herumlaufen
auf denen steht wir regieren Amerika so
sind es doch diejenigen die die Politik
machen sei es mit Politikern sei es mit
thinkanks sei es mit dem Militär sie
alle sind miteinander
verbunden geeint als geteilt sind es
gibt zwar Meinungsverschiedenheiten aber
es geht dabei um Methoden nicht um Ziele
wissen sie so sind einige der Meinung
dass man einige Atomwaffen abschaffen
sollte während andere meinen dass man
sie alle behalten sollte aber die
Unterschiede reichten wirklich von A bis
B wie man früher
sagte die tägliche Realität sieht so aus
dass diejenigen die hohe Positionen in
der Politik inne haben und starke
Verbindungen zu den Interessen und die
Geldinteressen selbst das Land
regieren wir sind jetzt auf dem Weg zum
Kongress der in der Öffentlichkeit
weniger als 10% Zustimmung
genießt wissen Sie woran sie einen
Kongressabgeordneten erkennen sie haben
hier eine kleine Anstecknadel und tragen
nie etwas bei sich das macht der
Assistent sie sehen lauter Leute die sie
anhimmeln leben in einer Blase sie
merken gar nicht dass das Land ihnen
gegenüber so zynisch ist
auch die Kongressabgeordneten sind
zynisch ich bin dem Abgeordneten John
kanas buchstäblich in einem dunklen Gang
begegnet er ist das dienstälteste
Mitglied und beklagt dass sie von
Lobbyisten überschwemmt werden sehen sie
dass viele Leute von der Wall Street dem
Kongress Spenden zukommen lassen und
versuchen Reformen zu
verhindern das sieht man nicht aber man
weiß dass es so ist sie haben nicht
aufgehört ich meine der Kongress wollte
die finanzgesetzeform
als ob sie auf regulatorischer Ebene
durch diese Spenden von Großbanken und
der Wall Street aufgehalten
werden n es wird sich zeigen in den
Quartalsberichten aber ich habe keinen
Grund zu glauben dass das aufgehört hat
oder reduziert wurde das Ergebnis ist
also dasselbe
stagnationust
ier Wochen später wurde berichtet dass
die Großbank JP Morgan Chase beim zocken
mit exotischen derivatprodukten 2
Milliarden Dollar verloren
hat und das was sie ein synthetisches
Kreditportfolio nannten wenn Jamie
Diamond diesen Fehler macht denn wir
wissen dass er gut ist was zum Teufel
ist dann bei der City Group und der Bank
of America los die Fehler von JP Morgan
der gemessen an den Vermögenswerten
größten US-Bank haben die Finanzwelt
aufgeschreckt für viele werden
Erinnerungen an 2008 als die riskanten
Wetten der Großbanken das Finanzsystem
zum Einsturz zu bringen drohten später
wurde berichtet dass sich die Lobbyisten
der Bank gegen eine neue Vorschrift
gewährt hatten deren Verabschiedung
diesen Riesenverlust verhindert hätte
die schlechte Nachricht machte im
Internet die
Runde da es sich um den Derivatemarkt
handelt ist dies sehr wichtig es könnte
sich als nichts herausstellen die größte
US-Bank ist mit der usnenbank bestens
befreundet und natürlich geht es hier um
eine ganze Menge
Schulden aber in keinem der Kommentare
die ich gesehen habe wurde die
Lobbyarbeit von JP Morgan Chase
erwähnt man sieht immer wieder wie
Banken in Probleme geraten ausrutschen
und Amerikas größte Bank JP Morgan tut
genau das offenesagt sind die Banken ihr
eigener schlimmster
Feind wir wissen dass wir schlampig und
dumm waren dass es ein schlechtes
Urteilsvermögen gab natürlich sollten
sich die Aufsichtsbehörden so etwas
ansehen wir sind bereit mit Ihnen
zusammenzuarbeiten wir werden die Sache
in Ordnung bringen daraus lernen und ein
besseres Unternehmen sein wenn es
abgeschlossen ist eine der
verblüffendsten Lehren aus allldem ist
dass die Unternehmen sich selbst nicht
unter Kontrolle haben so sehr dass sie
sogar ihre eigene Branche und ihre
eigenen Unternehmen zerstören das
kurzfristige Profitmotiv sckert in so
viele Poren von Einzelpersonen
Abteilungen Büros und ganzen Unternehmen
wir können Ihnen also definitiv nicht
zutrauen dass sie herausfinden wie sie
sich selbst kontrollieren
können spielte eine Rolle beim Verbot
des insiderhels von kongressmitglied mit
Informationen die Sie bei Anhörungen und
Untersuchungen erhalten hatten public
citizen betrachtete das als
Korruption der Gedanke dass die
mächtigen nicht eine Reihe von Regeln
für sich selbst aufstellen sollten aber
eine Reihe von Regeln für alle anderen
wenn wir erwarten dass das für unsere
größten Unternehmen und erfolgreichsten
Bürger gilt dann sollte es auch für
unsere gewählten Beamten gelten in einer
Zeit in der es ein vertrauensdefizit
gibt zwischen dieser Stadt und dem Rest
des
Landes der Kongressabgeordnete J Jackson
Junior Sohn des berühmten
Bürgerrechtlers vertritt seit 17 Jahren
einen Bezirk in
Chicago er hatte sich zur Aufgabe
gemacht zu untersuchen und zu erklären
wie das System historisch aufgebaut ist
um den Rechten der Staaten und
besonderen Interessen zu
dienen ich habe einen Antrag zur
Verfassungsänderung eingereicht um uns
das Recht auf eine öffentliche Bildung
von gleicher Qualität zu garantieren
weil jeder Amerikaner der eine
öffentliche Schule besucht nicht in der
Sklaverei der staatsrechte Leben sollte
die Lektion der Überwindung der
Verfassung durch die Afroamerikaner in
Bezug auf die Rechte der Bundesstaaten
wurde von den Amerikanern im Laufe der
Zeit nicht beherzigt und es ist genau
dieses System in dem sie heute
feststecken sie wissen es nur nicht wir
haben ihn gefragt warum der Kongress so
dysfunktional geworden
ist ich habe ihn noch nie so polarisiert
gesehen ich habe ihn noch nie so
gespalten gesehen entlang geographischer
Grenzen entlang Fraktionsgrenzen entlang
wirtschaftlicher und politischer
Grenzen das ist nicht das wofür die
Demokratie gedacht war es ist nicht das
wozu sie sich entwickeln sollte und
leider ist das amerikanische Volk das
Opfer dieses
Prozesses wie würden Sie die Frage
beantworten wer Amerika
regiert es gibt zwei Arten von
materieller macht in diesem Land und in
der Welt die eine ist politisch und die
andere wirtschaftlich wir das Volk haben
die politische Macht das
Wirtschaftssystem zu kontrollieren und
es gibt einen ständigen Kampf zwischen
der Macht des Volkes und der
wirtschaftlichen Macht wir das Volk
kontrollieren durch das politische
System unser wirtschaftliches Schicksal
und das der Nation die schwere Hand des
Wirtschaftssystems kontrolliert
zunehmend das politische System und
manipuliert das Volk wer kontrolliert
Amerika eine elitäre Gruppe von Menschen
die in einer Stratosphäre weltweit und
jenseits der Verfassung agieren jenseits
der Reichweite der Regierung sie
verfügen über enorme Ressourcen sie
besitzen die Medien und die Macht zu
recherchieren sie können das narrativ
der Geschichten gestalten sie können
Kandidaten für öffentliche Ämter
positionieren und dem amerikanischen
Volk ein Bild vermitteln das oft nicht
der Realität entspricht und doch sehen
die Amerikaner dieses Bild von einer
Führungspersönlichkeit und Stimmen für
sie nur um später die menschlichen
Schwächen und Unzulänglichkeiten der
Person zu
entdecken wir trafen uns mit einem
ehemaligen kongressmitarbeiter der 12
Jahre lang für einen führenden ab
gearbeitet hat er wollte dass wir sein
Gesicht Schwerzen und seine Stimme
verzerren er beschrieb schonungslos wie
Entscheidungen getroffen
werden es ist eine großartige
Institution aber leider gibt es
unzählige
Kongressabgeordnete die 60% ihrer Zeit
damit verbringen Geld zu beschaffen und
weil sie alle zwei Jahre kandidieren
müssen was keinen Sinn macht müssen sie
Millionen von Dollar aufbringen nur um
konkurrenzfähig zu sein um ins Fernsehen
zu kommen denn CBS ABC NBC und CNN
verlangen unverschämt viel Geld für
Fernsehwerbung es sollte kostenlos oder
sehr kostengünstig sein so kommt es dass
diese Kongressmitglieder sich auf
gutwillige Mitarbeiter verlassen viele
von ihnen kommen gerade aus dem College
viele von ihnen waren Praktikanten die
wichtige Entscheidungen in den Bereichen
außen und Innenpolitik Gesundheitswesen
beschäftig und Arbeitsplätze treffen
sollten aber sie sind noch nicht
wirklich reif
genug er sagte uns auch dass viele der
Mitarbeiter von Interessenvertretern und
Großspendern gekauft
werden viele dieser jungen Leute kommen
gerade aus dem College oder von der Uni
sie müssen diese enormen Kredite an das
College und die Uni zurückzahlen sie
zahlen unglaubliche mieten in Washington
DC und Nord Virginia oft mehr als ein
Drittel ihresinkom
viele von ihnen werden von Arbeitslosen
Familienmitgliedern betreut sie stehen
also unter dem Druck für die Geldgeber
in der Cas Street zu arbeiten viele
Mitarbeiter auch fortschrittliche
Mitarbeiter haben das Parlament
verlassen um für die großen
Pharmakonzerne oder Ölgesellschaften zu
arbeiten in der Regel sind es die
größten Unternehmen der jeweiligen
Branche die man sich ansch
wenn es um die gesamte nationale
Wirtschaftspolitik geht ist die Wall
Street der dominierende Einfluss ich
weiß nicht wie es in der Pharmaindustrie
aussieht dort haben die großen
Pharmakonzerne das Sagen in der
Finanzindustrie sind es immer noch die
größten Institutionen die die
Tagesordnung
bestimmen es gab Umfragen was der
Amerikaner glauben wohin das Geld in
unserer Regierung fließt und so gut wie
niemand hat eine Ahnung die Menschen
überschätzen bei weitem wie viel in die
Entwicklungshilfe fließt liegt zum Teil
daran dass wir die Bewaffnung fremder
Nationen als Hilfe bezeichnen und sie
unterschätzen wie viel für das Militär
ausgegeben wird und doch sagt unser
Informant ein ehemaliger Mitarbeiter des
Kongresses ist das wahre Problem nicht
nur die Macht der Unternehmen das größte
Problem in Amerika sind nicht die
Konzerne es ist nicht mal unbedingt das
Geld für die
Wahlkämpfe das größte Problem ist dass
die Amerikaner sich nicht wirklich in
ihren kongressbezirken organisieren um
die Macht der Special Interest zu
mindern sie machen keinen Gebrauch von
der Demokratie weil sie nicht wissen wie
das Spiel
funktioniert die Spender wissen genau
wie das Spiel funktioniert wenn man
einem Mitglied des Kongresses Geld gibt
wird er wahrscheinlich das tun worum er
gebeten wurde wenn man also Millionen
und aber Millionen von Menschen hat die
für Obama oder für ihren
Kongressabgeordneten gestimmt haben dann
ist das das Ende ihres politischen
Engagements dann ist das das Ende der
Demokratie
in keiner Serie darüber wer Amerika
regiert darf der Einfluss der Wall
Street auf die Finanzwelt fehlen wir
haben dessen Einfluss bis zum Schluss
aufgespart wohlwissend dass dieser
Finanzdistrikt im heutigen Amerika ein
zentrales Machtzentrum ist eine
Drehscheibe für die Finanzialisierung
einer Wirtschaft in der die Kontrolle
des großen Geldes zentral ist für die
Kontrolle von Politik und
Gesellschaft wir haben mit einem
angesehenen Unternehmensleiter
gesprochen der uns klipp und klar sagte
dass die reichen heute Amerika regieren
meine persönliche Meinung ist dass ein
großer Teil der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung auf die Globalisierung und
Digitalisierung der Wirtschaft
zurückzuführen ist das lässt sich nicht
aufhalten Professor stanleyonovitz
zitiert den berühmten Soziologen c w
Mills zum gleichen Thema vor 50
Jahren die Wall Stre der Finanzsektor
ist die führende Kraft des
unternehmenskapitals und sie war schon
Mitte der Jahre natürlich ist sie heute
viel stärker akzentuiert weil die
Industriekonzerne relativ zurückgegangen
sind ich habe Dinge gehört die sie
umhauen werden und ich denke es ist
jetzt an der Zeit dass sie die ganze
Geschichte erfahren viele Amerikaner
sehen all das als eine Verschwörung
einer nicht rechenschaftspflichtigen
geheimen Kabale die wie ein Machtzentrum
jenseits der demokratischen Kontrolle
agiert das Internet ist voll von Videos
über Milliardäre und ihre Komplotte
kontrollieren es passiert genau jetzt es
handelt sich um eine Verschwörung der
institutionellen Korruption auf höchster
Ebene von den internationalen Bankern
bis zu den Superreichen von Washington
bis Rom sie alle stecken unter einer
Decke ist die Wall Street eine
Verschwörung welche Rolle spielt sie bei
der Frage wer Amerika regiert ist es ein
Job von außen oder von
innen es geht nicht um Eliten außerhalb
des Staates obwohl sie natürlich enormen
Einfluss haben aber der Grund warum sie
enormen Einfluss haben ist dass der
Staat so strukturiert ist dass ihre
Macht und Autorität in der Gesellschaft
reproduziert Leo P ist
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler und
Analytiker und ich glaube er hat eine
Perspektive aufgezeigt die wir bisher
noch nicht gehört
haben er kämpft gegen die
verschwörerische Vorstellung D eine
kleine Gruppe von Menschen irgendwo in
einem Raum die Dinge steuert er spricht
über die Struktur der
ihre Werte und darüber wer wirklich das
Sagen hat die Wall Street ist eine
Industrie mit tausenden von miteinander
verbundenen Unternehmen die sich selbst
als
Finanzdienstleistungsbranche
bezeichnen aber sie sind viel mehr als
das sie haben großen Einfluss darauf wie
unser Land geführt wird sagt Robert
weseman der Leiter der öffentlichen
Interessengruppe public citizen man kann
nicht verstehen was in den letzten 30
Jahren im Bezug auf die
Wirtschaftspolitik passiert ist und wie
sich das Land politisch entwickelt hat
ohne zu verstehen wie die Wall Street an
Macht gewonnen hat sie hat an
wirtschaftlicher und politischer Macht
gewonnen und das hat zu Synergieeffekten
geführt sie nutzen ihre politische Macht
um Vorschriften
auszuhebeln früher kauften Anleger
Aktien von Unternehmen und Branchen die
Arbeitsplätze
schufen Dienstleistungen erbrachten oder
wertvolle Produkte herstellten diese
Zeiten sind vorbei sie machten einen
immer größeren Teil der Wirtschaft aus
dann gingen wir von einer Wirtschaft der
Produktion zu einer Wirtschaft über die
auf Konsum dem Kauf und Verkauf von
Dingen basiert bald machten die
Verbraucher 70% der Wirtschaft aus
während Banken Private Equity
Unternehmen und Hedgefonds immer größer
wurden je größer ihr Anteil an der
Wirtschaft wurde desto mehr politische
Macht konnten sie ausüben in einem für
das Funktionieren der Demokratie
wirklich schrecklichen Kreislauf das
führte zum Crash
2008 die Verbraucher verschuldeten sich
immer mehr und die Bänker kauften und
verkauften Schulden während sie die
Regeln für ihre Aktivitäten
änderten eine ganze Reihe von
deregulierungsmaßnahmen die durch den
politischen Einfluss der Wall Street
ermöglicht wurden führten dazu dass das
funktionierende Wirtschaft zur
Katastrophe
wurde denn wie mit der Milliardär und
Investor geor s vor Jahren sagte ist die
kapitalistische Wirtschaft von Natur aus
instabil anfäig für blasen und
Zusammenbrüche ich gehe von der Theorie
aus dass die Finanzmärkte von Natur aus
instabil
sind um Exzesse zu verhindern braucht
man eine Art von
Intervention Überwachung
Regulierung leider ist die
vorherrschende Vorstellung dass die
Märkte zum Gleichgewicht
tendieren und so arbeiten wir mit einer
alchen Vorstellung davon wie
Finanzmärkte
funktionieren jemand hat uns z.B gesagt
dass das Schöne an der Globalisierung
ist dass niemand die Kontrolle
hat nun das ist ein großer Vorteil denn
Kontrollen haben ihre eigenen Probleme
tatsächlich sind Märkte viel effizienter
als zentralisierte Kontrollen aber das
bedeutet nicht dass es absolut keine
Kontrolle geben
sollte und wenn man sich die Realität
anschaut dann hat es seit es den
Kapitalismus und die Finanzmärkte gibt
immer wieder Krisen gegeben und jedes
Mal wenn es eine Krise gab wurde etwas
unternommen um eine Wiederholung zu
verhindern das Problem dieses Mal ist
der dramatische Anstieg der Schulden
sehen Sie hier das sind Diagramme die
die Verschuldung der USA zeigen Seite
für Seite die zeigen wie viel geldesch
es ist
verblüffend noch komplizierter wird es
wenn man über neue Finanzinstrumente wie
Derivate spricht die die Branche in ein
globales Casino verwandelt haben
Derivate können auch als Versicherung
eingesetzt werden indem man darauf
wettet dass ein Kredit vor einem
bestimmten Datum ausfällt oder nicht sie
werden zur Grundlage eines großen
wettsystems wie in einem Casino der
finanzjournalist Max Kaiser sagt nur
eine Handvoll großeran Unternehmen die
Branche und die Weltwirtschaft
beherrschen zweifellos JP Moran steckt
mit der Fett unter einer Decke es ist
ein
zentralbankensystem die Wall Street
wettet auf zukünftige Werte und die
Entwicklung von praktisch allem was
wertvoll
ist Morgan und Goldman Sax sind die
beiden Hauptakteure in dieser globalen
Finanzwelt bald wurden CEOs Finanziers
und Führungskräfte einer kleinen Anzahl
von Investmentbanken und Hedgefonds
reich und mch
indem sie spezialisierte Märkte mit
hohen Einsätzen
kontrollierten sie sind mit dem
zentralbanksystem verbunden also mit der
Fed der
EZB die Bank für internationalen
Zahlungsausgleich in der Schweiz ist
sowas wie die Zentralbank der
Zentralbanken ihr Hauptzweck ist es die
Zinssätze so nahe wie möglich bei Null
zu halten damit die Leute die sich Geld
zum Spekulieren Lein so billig wie
möglich spekulieren können ohne für das
Geld dass sie sich zum spekulieren
zahlen zu müssen auch wenn diese
Finanzmärkte angeblich für alle offen
sind haben einige wenige Händler
Investoren und Vermögensverwalter die
Märkte so strukturiert dass sie ihren
eigenen Reichtum und ihre Macht
vergrößern
können wenn sie einmal eine schlechte
Wette eingehen versuchen Sie schnell sie
mit Sparprogrammen oder eine Art
Rettungsprogramm oder einem Programm zur
quantitativen Lockerung zu
decken eine Schweizer Studie von
Physikern über die Eigentumsverhältnisse
und die Kontrolle von in 48 Ländern
untersuchte
24877 Aktien und
Aktieninhaber zu ihrem Erstaunen
stellten sie fest dass nur Zeh
Unternehmen den gesamten Aktienbesitz
dominieren hier sind
sie wenn wir über Geld und die Wall
Street sprechen müssen wir uns die Frage
stellen woher das Geld kommt mit dem auf
unseren Finanzmärkten spekuliert
wird dieser Mann weiß es Barry James
dike er ist Vermögensverwalter und
arbeitet mit Kunden woher kommt das
also das Geld kommt aus parnissen den
Rentenfonds der Leute die für den
Ruhestand
sparen aber wissen die Leute die Geld
auf diese Konten einzahlen wie es
ausgegeben wird sie haben nicht die
geringste Ahnung erst jetzt als Folge
der Finanzkrise erfährt die
Öffentlichkeit langsam dass die
selbsternannten Herren des Universums an
der Wall Street mit riskanten
Investitionen t und einen Crash
verursacht
haben Graden Carter der Herausgeber von
Vanity Fair schrieb man könne mit Fug
und Recht behaupten dass sich die Kette
katastrophaler wetten die einige hundert
Denker im letzten Jahrzehnt
abgeschlossen haben als das größte
gewaltlose Verbrechen gegen die
Menschheit in der Geschichte
herausstellen könnte sie haben die
Weltwirtschaft in die Knie gezwungen
Dutzende von Millionen Menschen um ihren
Arbeitsplatz und ihr zu Hause gebracht
und die Altersvorsorge einer ganzen
Generation zuichte gemacht und sie
könnten schätzungsweise 200 Millionen
Menschen weltweit in bittere Armut
Treiben im Jahr 2010 vor Occupy Wall
Street demonstrierten die Gewerkschaften
gegen die Verbrechen der Wall
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Street am 29 April findet ein Marsch auf
die Wall Street statt der von der AFL
organisiert wird die nach eigenen
Angaben bisher 200 Proteste organisiert
hat was man aber aufgrund der
Medienberichterstattung nicht
weiß nun heute sind die Medien draußen
und sie marschieren wegen eines
Diebstahls Millionen von Arbeitsplätzen
sind verschwunden laut AFL CIO 11
Millionen sie wollen Rache sie wollen
die Wall Street zur Kasse bitten sie
wollen eine neue Steuer auf
Finanztransaktionen
[Musik]
wir versuchen uns von einer Finanzkrise
zu erholen von der manche sagen sie sei
noch schlimmer als die Depression in den
30er Jahren und dennoch werden die
vorgeschlagenen Reformen die sehr
bescheiden sind von den Wall Street
Firmen und Finanziers auf
regulatorischer Ebene mit Händen und
Füßen
bekämpftauben sie dass sie einen
unverhältnismäßig großen Einfluss auf
den Kongress
haben daran gibt es keinen Zweifel nicht
nur auf den Kongress sondern auch auf
die Parlamente der Bundesstaaten ihre
Macht zieht sich durch das gesamte
amerikanische politische
System ich habe gelesen dass die
Finanzdienstleistungsbranche 28
Lobbyisten pro kongressmitglied
eingestellt hat um zu versuchen deren
Entscheidungen zu beeinflussen was
passiert mit ihnen wenn Lobbyisten in
ihr Büro kommen und versuchen sie dazu
zu bringen in ihrem Sinne zu stimmen wie
funktioniert
das es ist sehr schwer einen Termin bei
mir zu bekommen ich glaube nicht dass
sie viel Geld ausgeben um mich zu
beeinflussen ich bin mir über meine
Auffassung von einer repräsentativen
Regierung im klaren und von der
Verfassung mein Bezirk ist zwar
konkurrenzfähig aber es gibt noch viel
mehr konkurrenzfähige Bezirke als meinen
und jedes kongressmitglied wird in
diesem Maße zum Gefangenen des
Wahlprozesses und des Prozesses der
Mittelbeschaffung sheil Krumholz vom
Center for responsive politics sagt die
Macht der Wall Street sei gut
dokumentiert die Wall Street die Banken
und die Finanzindustrie im Allgemeinen
sind die größte einzelquelle für
Wahlkampfgelder in den USA und das schon
seit Jahren wenn nicht Jahrzehnten man
geht dorthin wo das Geld ist sie haben
nicht nur politische Aktionskomitees die
einflussreichen Kongressmitgliedern die
für ihre Bran zuständig sind
Höchstbeträge zukommen lassen können
sondern Sie können auch Hunderttausende
von Dollar allein unter ihren Partnern
und Vizepräsidenten und Führungskräften
in ihren Unternehmen
auftreiben sie sagt dass ihr Einfluss
die Wahl 2012 beeinflussen
wird sie können eine Menge Geld
auftreiben und das zeigt sich auch ganz
konkret im Präsidentschaftswahlkampf
2012 womit Romney aus der Private Equity
Branche kommt und Barack Obama davor der
Liebling der Wall Street
war die Wall Street und insbesondere die
Banken sind also ein enorm
einflussreicher Teil der
US-Industrie diese Macht wird deutlich
wenn Lobbyisten der Wall Street
versuchen die vom Kongress
verabschiedeten finanzreformen zu
sabotieren tun die Regulierungsbehörden
nach der Verabschiedung eines Gesetzes
das was der Kongress ihnen aufgetragen
hat im Großen und Ganzen nein sie sind
mit dem Erlass der Vorschriften weit in
Verzug dort wo sie Regeln erlassen haben
werden sie fast immer von der
Handelskammer dem financial securities
Roundtable oder anderen Wall Street
Interessen vor Gericht angefochten mit
einer Justiz die dem Großkapital
wohlgesonnen ist haben sie es schwer die
von ihnen erlassenen Regeln aufrecht
zuerhalten Reformen können also
verabschiedet aber auch sabotiert
werden ja sie bekommen mehrere Bisse in
den Apfel einen im Kongress wo sie
enorme Macht haben aber zumindest ist es
meist ein öffentlicher Kampf und dann
gehen Sie zu den Regulierungsbehörden wo
es unter dem Radar passiert es gibt
keine öffentliche Kontrolle kürzlich
diskutierte ich in einer Radiosendung
mit den Finanzjournalisten Max Kaiser
und Stacy Herbert über die Macht der
Wall Street und den finanziellen
Zusammenbruch sowie mit Andy stepanien
einem Tierschützer der eine Kampagne
gegen ein Unternehmen führte das
schmerzhafte medizinische Tests an
Welten durchführt nachdem seine Gruppe
den aktienk in den Keller getrieben
hatte ging das Unternehmen pleite aber
dann bezeichnete ihn die Regierung als
finanzterroristen und schickte ihn ins
Gefängnis zu Beginn haben wir die Wall
Street mit der Titanic verglichen dem
unsinkbaren Schiff das gesunken
ist wäre die Titanic die Geschichte von
heute wäre der Unterschied dass Goldman
Sax und JP Morgan schwere Wetten darauf
eingegangen wären dass das Schiff sinkt
und Hank Paulson wäre dort unten um den
Riss zu
vergrößern
das bringt mich zu einer neuen Studie
die erst kürzlich veröffentlicht wurde
und in der hunderte von Schiffswracks
der letzten paar hundert Jahre
untersucht wurden sie fanden heraus dass
Frauen und Kinder in der Regel häufiger
sterben als Männer und dass der Kapitän
normalerweise nicht mit dem Schiff
untergeht bei ihnen war die
Überlebensrate in der Regel am
höchsten diese Leute verwenden Derivate
Warren Buffett nennt sie finanzielle
Massenvernichtungswaffen um die
Situation zu verschlimmern weil sich
ihre Wetten darauf diese Katastrophen
schlimmer werden enorm auszahlen das
sehen wir an den Zahlen an den Boni
daran spiegelt es sich
wiedery du hast vorhin genickt als Max
über all das gesprochen
hat stimmt es wirklich dass sie
gewissermaßen gegen uns wetten dass sie
hoffen dass schlimme Dinge
passieren ich glaube nicht dass jeder an
der Wall Street diese Mentalität hat
aber es gibt eine Kultur in der die
Leute gelernt haben mE Verhalten
zumindest zu eptieren wie z.B diese
Investitionen die Wetten gegen das
Scheitern von Dingen sei es eine
Regierung ein Land oder ein Unternehmen
und zu sagen oh gut ich kann das
rechtfertigen und man betrachtet es wie
Zahlen man schaut nicht auf die Menschen
die dahinter stehen man schaut nicht auf
die Familien die darunter leiden auf das
Land das darunter
leidet was mich verblüfft ist die
Tatsache dass sie ein Bild der Absicht
zeichnen dass die Menschen Dinge taten
um ihre eigenen Interessen zu fördern
sie wussten was sie taten es war
kalkuliert und doch scheint es in den
meisten Medien so als ob es eine Art
Fehler als Fehlkalkulation dargestellt
wird wir wollten ja dass der
Immobilienmarkt steigt aber ist gesunken
man kann uns nicht die Schuld geben
jeder hat es getan also hat es keiner
getan also kann auch niemand belangt
werden wenn es eine Absicht gab ist das
gut oder schlecht manche sagen es ist
gut dass es in einer Wirtschaft Menschen
gibt die Parasiten sind denn sie sind
nützlich ich habe Parasiten in meinen
dermen sie erfüllen eine wichtige
Funktion das Problem ist dass Parasiten
nicht mein Herz meine Lunge und mein
Gehirn kontrollieren in Amerika
schreiben die Parasiten die Regeln die
eigentlich sie kontrollieren sollten
also haben sie das Sagen beeinflusst die
Wall Street das Kapital unsere Politik
nun sie werden zu politischen
Entscheidungsträgern zumindest für kurze
Zeit und kehren dann wieder zu den
Banken
zurück es ist also eine Art Drehtür
im Wesentlichen ob unter Bush oder Obama
die Positionen im Kabinett die das
Finanzwesen Regeln werden von früheren
Bankenchefs besetzt oder sie kehren
vielleicht als Ehrenvorsitzende in den
Vorstand zurück es ist diese incestuöse
Beziehung zwischen der Wall Street und
den politischen
Entscheidungsträgern das klingt so
korrupt sie fragen wer Amerika regiert
und ich sage es ist die unwissenheitomas
Jefferson hat gewarnt dass wir Medien
brauchen die Bevölkerung informieren
sonst verlieren wir unsere Demokratie es
ist die Unwissenheit die uns
aufgezwungen wird die das Wissen
kriminalisiert das ist etwas worüber ich
erschrocken war als die nasdec am
timesquare eröffnete ein großes Studio
mit einem großen Fenster vor der Tür und
ich sagte ich würde gerne die Börse
besichtigen das war zu der Zeit als
Bernie madof die nasdck
leitete und sie sagten sie können die
Börse nicht besichtigen es gibt keine es
sieht aus wie eine Börse es gibt ein
Gebäude auf dem nestdeck steht aber der
eigentliche Betrieb sind
Computer der algorithmische Handel geht
weit darüber hinaus es geht nicht um
Einzelpersonen die ein Risiko eingehen
um einen Markt als Teil eines
kapitalistischen Systems zu schaffen es
sind Computer die über einen praktisch
unbegrenzten Kredit verfügen da die
Kreditkosten jetzt bei Null liegen eine
Bank wie JP morgon mit einer 90
Billionen Dollar Bilanz an Derivaten
kann einem Computerprogramm eine Billion
um eine Wette abzuschließen wenn sie
nicht aufgeht gibt es eine staatliche
Rettungsaktion wenn sie aufgeht bekommen
sie einen Bonus das geht schon seit
Jahren so aber es ist noch
unverhältnismäßiger und asymmetrischer
geworden diese Verlagerung hin zu super
schnellen Computern ist nur ein weiteres
Beispiel für die tiefgreifende
Machtverschiebung die Finanzwelt
übernimmt faktisch die Macht und die
Politiker umwerben die Wall Street auf
globalen Konferenzen und bei privaten
Treffen ge Soros
erklärt das ist eigentlich symptomatisch
für das Zeitalter in dem Präsidenten und
Premierminister die Finanziers und
industriellen
umwerben es zeigt eine Verschiebung der
relativen
Machtverhältnisse aber ich glaube nicht
dass die Wirtschaft in irgendeiner WE
die Macht des Staates ersetzen kann denn
es ist eine andere Art von macht die
Souveränität liegt also immer noch in
den Händen des
Staates es klingt wie eine
Verschwörungstheorie aber die Wall
Street kontrolliert alles sie sind die
Hauptaktionäre aller großen Unternehmen
sehen Sie sich die bpölpest an der
größte Aktionär JP mor es passiertade
viel
nicht mehr aufzuhalten jeder weiß dass
das System kaputt ist egal ob man zu dem
ein% oder den 99% gehört ein
Republikaner ist ein Demokrat ein
Anarchist Kommunist Kapitalist jeder
weiß dass das System kaputt ist also
müssen wir es jetzt
reparieren das letzte Wort hat ein
Wissenschaftler mit
Weitblick der Historiker
er
hab Defizit zu tun nicht nur in den USA
sondern auch in vielen anderen Ländern
ich will nicht ganz sagen dass eine
Plutokratie alles bestimmt was in den
USA geschieht aber ich glaube das
Demokratiedefizit ergibt sich aus der
Tatsache dass grundsätzliche Fragen von
der Demokratie ausgeschlossen sind es
spielt keine Rolle wer gewählt wird bei
den grundlegenden Fragen der Finanzen
der Deindustrialisierung und dergleichen
geht es um die Globalisierung um den
Verlust der Macht der einfachen Leute
über ihr eigenes Leben das steht nicht
zur Diskussion es ist mir egal ob es
sich um Demokraten Republikaner Obama
oder Romney handelt das ist nicht Teil
ihrer Debatte ihre Debatte findet am
Rande statt sodass die grundlegenden
Fragen mit denen die normalen Menschen
konfrontiert sind nicht Gegenstand
demokratischer Überlegungen sind die
Regierung vertritt nicht das einfache
Volk obwohl die Menschen sie wählen geht
sie überhaupt nicht auf Ihre Bedürfnisse
ein in dieser Serie sind wir der Frage
nachgegangen wer Amerika regiert haben
die Geschichte der tiefgreifenden
Konflikte in diesem Land untersucht die
bis zur amerikanischen Revolution
zurückreichen wir haben die Macht des
Militärs der Unternehmen der Medien und
der Wall Street unter die Lupe genommen
haben gezeigt dass diese mächtigen
Kräfte die Demokratie oft eher
untergraben als sie
stärken es ist ein Kampf um die Seele
Amerikas darum wer Amerika regiert er
hat diese tiefen Fragen aufgeworfen die
Frage ist ob ein grundlegender Wandel
möglich ist oder ob special interests
und die Wohlhabenden Amerikaner
weiterhin in einem Land dominieren
werden das von sich behauptet die
dynamischste Demokratie der Welt zu sein
der Glaube an unsere Demokratie hat fast
etwas Religiöses auch wenn es eine
Trennung von Kirche und Staat
gibt vielleicht ist das der Grund warum
die Ansichten die Sie in dieser Reihe
gehört haben vom Establishment von der
Wissenschaft und von der Presse
abgelehnt werden
sie glauben dass nur das Volk die Macht
hat wenn überhaupt aber die
Meinungsführer befassen sich nicht damit
sie konzentrieren sich nicht auf
Interessen sie konzentrieren sich auf
Ideologien auf Persönlichkeiten nicht
auf Institutionen der Gedanke an eine
Machtelite ist ihnen ein
Greuel denn wenn die Menschen daran
glauben würden könnte das zu
Unzufriedenheit und Dissens
führen im Zeitalter des Internets und
des globalen Fernsehens kann man nicht
verhindern dass die Menschen mit
gegenberichten zu den offiziellen myen
konfrontiert werden über diese Themen
lässt sich natürlich streiten aber in
der politischen Berichterstattung werden
andere Sichtweisen auf die Welt meist
nicht diskutiert die üblichen Experten
recycelen konventionelle
Weisheiten sie fragen nicht wer Amerika
regiert geehrte Mitglieder des
Kongresses ich habe das große Privileg
und die besondere Ehre Ihnen den
Präsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten zu
[Applaus]
präsentieren